in three months we've involved over
11,000 patients this makes it by far the
biggest clinical trial in the world and
we've been testing six different drugs a
couple of weeks ago we declared an
answer on hydroxychloroquine showing
that in hospitalized patients it doesn't
work and this week we've got some news
on dexamethasone which as we've heard is
a steroid drunk it's an old drug some
people would say it's a very boring drug
it's been around for 60 odd years it's
very cheap
it costs pounds and overseas it cost
pennies and so we closed that arm of the
trial on Monday the 8th of June because
we had enrolled more than 2,000 patients
on dexamethasone and we compared them to
4,000 patients who had standard of care
and what we saw was really quite
remarkable so we've looked at different
treatment groups and the drug has a
different treatment effect in different
treatment groups so in in ventilated
patients with coffered 19 the drug
dexamethasone so 10 days of treatment
with that which is a tablet or oral
injection reduces the risk of death by
about 35% in patients on the ward who
require oxygen and have covered it
reduces the risk of death by about 20%
that covers about 75% of patients in the
hospital who will receive a mortality
benefit from using this drug there's
another group of patients who don't
require oxygen but have covered and we
did not see a benefit in those patients
so it's not a drug that you would use in
the community or in outpatients or in
patients on the ward who didn't have
breathing difficulties but in patients
with breathing difficulties who require
oxygen or ventilation it really is
showing quite a significant effect and
it's really important because the drug
itself is very widely available it's on
it almost every pharmacy shelf in every
hospital it's available throughout the
world and it's extremely cheap so we've
looked at the numbers and if we treat
eight patients in intensive care with
this drug will save one life and the
total cost of treating all eight
patients is only about 40 pounds so this
is really really remarkable we're
extremely pleased with this result